[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
so now what this is when the operatic
section comes in oh the operatic section
yeah Mamma Mia Mamma Mia
it goes on forever six bloody minutes
it's your wife if you think six minutes
is forever
your mission should you choose to accept
it I wonder did you have to choose not
to the end war was feared is coming and
the blood will be on your hands
the fallout off all your good intentions
you had a terrible choice to make in
Berlin one life over millions and now
the world is at risk this is the CIA's
mission if he had held on to the
plutonium we wouldn't be having this
conversation this Tim you'd be dead
yes they would that's the job
[Music]
you don't understand what you're
involved in you need to walk away please
don't make me codes for you how many
times as hunts government's betrayed him
disavowed him cast him aside how long
before a man like that has had enough
we are
so how is he oh you know same always
how's he doing find it best not to hook
[Music]
there were dragons when I was a boy
where they went
only a few know our story changed the
world forever we did it the world's
first dragon Viking utopia Julia don't
be a maybe Mike / Glenda did more Oh
Santa honey hey buddy wait up
oh my god he's not the only one she's a
light fury here oh sorry did he just
disappear
[Music]
Wow
it's a hidden dragon worth
toothless go introduce yourself has a
girlfriend I've hunted every Night Fury
except yours hand him over I will never
give him up then I will destroy
everything you love
we are no longer safe here we all have
to disappear completely off the map we
have to fight for their freedom
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't nothing without your dragon
[Music]
show them what you got
[Music]
save him
as you and me bud always
I have seen gods fly I've seen men build
weapons that I couldn't even imagine
I've seen aliens drop from the sky
yeah but I have never seen anything like
this
how much more you hiding
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
my son it is your time
my respected
you get to decide what kind of thing you
are going to be
don't freeze I never freeze
[Music]
not be televised
show me my respect and bow Jam
I waited my entire life for this the
world's gonna start over I'm a burn at
all what happens now
determines what happens to the rest of
the world
[Music]
everything the light touches is our
kingdom but a king's time as ruler rises
and falls like the Sun one day
the Sun was set on my time here
and will rise with you as the new king
[Music]
remember my father was a lighthouse
keeper
my mother was a queen but life has a way
of bringing people together could unite
our bones one day check it out author is
talking to the fish
they made me what I am
so listen to come aboard
[Music]
I've been looking for you your half
brother King arm is about to declare war
upon the surface world
the only way to stop this war is for you
to take your rightful place as king
trust me I know
you do your best thinking when you're
not thinking at all that was the worst
pep talk ever
I want to strap in
my brother has come from the service
chose me for the throne I got an
ass-whooping
[Music]
I'm the leader
I came because I had no choice
you came and saved my home and the
people that I loved
you think your unmovable lead because
you have two different worlds
that is exactly why you are worthy
was awesome
the war is coming to the surface
and I'm bringing the wrath of the seven
seas with me
[Music]
oh yeah got involved if you want me to
drive you we gotta go no I want personal
chauffeur go horse okay seriously dad
walking would have been fine
breaking news spider-man saves the day I
guess spider-man this guy swings in once
the day zip zap zop gosh don't cops run
red lights oh yeah some do but uh not
your dad in your universe there's only
one spider-man but there's another
universe it looks it sounds like yours
but it's not my name is Miles Morales
thank you you like me
I knew my day would come around this
time I know it's complicated
want to know what happened to you I can
teach you to be spider-man hmm I love
this burger so delicious well the best
burgers I've ever had
you have money right I'm not very liquid
right now think you're gonna be a bad
teacher how am I supposed to save the
whole world you can't think about state
in the world you have to think about
saving one person one thing I know for
sure don't do it like me do it like you
[Applause]
[Music]
I see the spark in you it's amazing
paired up whatever you choose to do with
it you'll be great
I love you mom
dad I love you gotta copy swing just
like I thought when did you teach me
that I didn't it's a little joke the
team-building hey guys okay
who are you I'm Gwen Stacy come on how
much body people are there same as a
comic-con what so the entire time I knew
him he only ever had one goal
to wipe out half the universe if he gets
all the Infinity stones she can do it
with the snap of his fingers just like
that tell me his name again
Santos
[Music]
we got one advantage
she's coming to us
we have a terrace once so that's what we
use
[Music]
let's talk about this plan here's I
think it's good except it sucks so let
me do the plan and that way it might be
really good
Wow
the end is near
and um
[Music]
half of humanity will still exist
perfectly balanced
as all things should be
I hope that remember you
[Music]
I'm Peter by the way dr. strange Oh
using your made-up names then I am
spider-man
[Music]
this thing on
hey miss Ponce if you find this
recording don't feel bad about this part
of the journey is the end
[Music]
just for the record being adrift in
space with zero promise of rescue is
more fun that sounds food and water went
out four days ago
oxygen I'll run out tomorrow morning
I've been when I drift off I will dream
about you it's how I see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
danos did exactly what he said he was
gonna do
he wiped out 50% of all living creatures
we lost all of us
lost friends to us family
who lost a part of ourselves
this is the fight of our lives this has
been work Steve I know it is cuz I don't
know what I'm gonna do if it doesn't
hi is anyone home this is Scott Lang we
met a few years ago at the airport in
Germany not really big is just an old
message I know you know that that's me
can you buzz me
hello
there's anyone there
I'm trying to reach
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
senators we believe that these Titans
are just the tip of the iceberg which of
these Titans are here to protect us and
[Music]
which of these Titans are here to
threaten us
so you'd want to make Godzilla our pet
no we would be his you're sure he's
gonna be okay
they're everywhere battling for
dominance
arrival outfit to Godzilla you gotta be
kidding
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]